♪ ♪
>> Tucker: UNTIL NOT LONG AGO
WE SERVED AS ATTORNEY GENERAL OF
THE UNITED STATES.
NOW HE IS SPEAKING ON CAMERA FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE HE LEFT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
IF THERE ARE RUMORS SWIRLING
THAT HE COULD RUN FOR THE SENATE
SEAT THAT HE HELD FOR TWO
DECADES.
WILL HE DO THAT?
JEFF SESSIONS JOINS US ON SET
TONIGHT.
THANK YOU FOR COMING.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER, GOOD TO BE
WITH YOU.
>> Tucker: ARE YOU RUNNING FOR
SENATE?
>> YES, WE WILL FILE PAPERS
TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE RUNNING FOR
THE SEAT THAT YOU HELD.
AFTER THE COACH OF THE ALABAMA
FOOTBALL TEAM, THE MOST FAMOUS
PERSON IN THE STATE.
DO YOU REGRET LEAVING IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
>> I HAD A GREAT TENURE AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND SO
MANY DIFFERENT WAYS.
AND I DON'T EVER WORRY ABOUT
REGRETTING THINGS LIKE THAT.
WE WERE ABLE TO SERVE.
WE WERE ABLE TO PUSH THE TRUMP
AGENDA, AND DO IT IN AN
HONORABLE WAY.
AND IT WAS A GREAT EXPERIENCE.
I SPENT 15 YEARS IN THE
DEPARTMENT, SO, AND I DO NOT
REGRET THAT.
IT WAS AN HONOR TO SERVE, AND I
AM, IT IS NOT MY SEAT IN THE
SENATE, BUT I BELIEVE THAT I
HAVE SOMETHING TO GIVE.
I HAVE SOME CONVICTIONS THAT I
THINK NEED TO BE PUSHED.
WE NEED TO GET SOME REPUBLICANS
MOVING.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN PUSHING HARD
ENOUGH TO ADVANCE THE TRUMP
AGENDA.
SO THAT'S WHAT I LOOK FORWARD TO
DOING.
AND I THINK I CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
THAT.
>> Tucker: POLITICS INTRUDED
ON YOUR TENURE AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE PAID WE CAN GET TO
THAT IN A MINUTE.
BUT IT RAISES YOUR RELATIONSHIP
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP THAT YOU
BROUGHT FORWARD IN A POLITICAL
AD.
I DON'T THINK IT HAS APPEARED
ANYWHERE BUT HERE NOW.
>> DID I RIGHT A TELL-ALL BOOK?
NO.
OH DID I GO ON CNN AND THE
ATTACKED THE PRESIDENT?
NO.
HAVE I SAID A CROSS WORD ABOUT
OUR PRESIDENT?
NOT ONE TIME.
I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
FIRST, THAT WOULD BE
DISHONORABLE.
I WAS THERE TO SERVE HIS AGENDA,
NOT MINE.
SECOND, THE PRESIDENT IS DOING A
GREAT JOB.
FOR AMERICA AND ALABAMA, AND HE
HAS MY STRONG SUPPORT.
>> Tucker: HE HAS YOUR STRONG
SUPPORT.
DO YOU HAVE HIS STRONG SUPPORT?
>> I HOPE SO, I THINK HE WILL
RESPECT MY WORK.
I WAS THERE FOR THE TRUMP AGENDA
EVERY DAY.
I WAS IN THE SENATE, NO DOUBT
ABOUT IT.
I WAS THE FIRST REPUBLICAN AND
SENATOR TO ENDORSE HIM.
WE PUSHED THE IMMIGRATION
AGENDA.
THE TRADE AGENDA.
AND BEGAN TO WORK FOR A
REALISTIC FOREIGN POLICY.
IT DOES NOT GET US IN ENDLESS
WARS.
HE WAS RIGHT ABOUT ALL THREE OF
THOSE.
THAT'S WHERE THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE, AND THIS REPUBLICAN
CONGRESS.
AND THE WHOLE CONGRESS NEEDS TO
LISTEN TO THAT.
>> Tucker: IRONICALLY, YOU ARE
ONE OF THE VERY FEW PEOPLE IN
THE ADMINISTRATION WHO AGREED
WITH HIM ON HIS SIGNATURE
ISSUES.
MOST DIDN'T AND WORK TO
UNDERMINE HIM FOR THREE YEARS.
BUT YOU GOT INTO RUSSIA, HE WAS
FURIOUS ABOUT THAT, DO YOU
REGRET THAT DECISION?
>> NO, I DID THE THING THAT I
HAD TO DO ABOUT RULES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
THE SENIOR ADVISORS TOLD ME THAT
THIS IS WHAT THE RULES REQUIRE,
THE REGULATIONS REQUIRED, AND I
READ THEM, AND I DON'T THINK
THERE WAS ANY DOUBT FROM ME.
BUT I KNOW HOW PAINFUL IT WAS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE WHOLE THING WAS VERY
PAINFUL FOR HIM.
AND HE SAW THIS AS A PIVOTAL
MOMENT.
BUT PAINFUL AND PROLONGED AS IT
WAS, IT DID CLEAR HIM OF RUSSIAN
COLLUSION, AND I'M CERTAINLY
GLAD THAT THAT FINALLY HAPPENED.
>> Tucker: HE IS VERY POPULAR
IN THE STATE OF ALABAMA, AS YOU
KNOW.
AS YOUR AD SUGGESTS.
YOU DON'T WANT HIM TO COME OUT
AGAINST YOU, OF COURSE.
ARE YOU GOING TO TALK TO THEM
ABOUT IT?
>> I WILL.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HAVING
THAT OPPORTUNITY AND HAVING
PROVIDED IT AT THIS MOMENT.
BUT I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
GO TO THE PEOPLE OF ALABAMA AND
TELL THEM WITH ALL HONESTY, I
BELIEVE IN THIS AGENDA.
I WAS FOR THIS AGENDA BEFORE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED, AND I
SUPPORTED IT WHEN HE WAS
PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS RESIN RUN
PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS RESIN RUI
PRESIDENT, WHEN HE WAS RESIN RUG
FOR PRESIDENT.
I SUPPORTED HIM.
AND IF I RETURN TO THE SENATE --
NO NO SENATOR WILL BE MORE FOR
ADVANCING TRUMPS AGENDA THAN I
WILL BE.
>> Tucker: I BELIEVE THAT.
I WAS THERE, AND YOU WERE MAKING
THE SAME CASE THAT YOU ARE
MAKING NOW.
WHAT ABOUT YOUR FELLOW
REPUBLICANS WHO REMAIN IN THE
SENATE?
DO YOU THINK AFTER THREE YEARS
THEY BUY THE TRUMP AGENDA?
>> I THINK SOME OF THEM ARE
STILL STANDOFFISH.
AND SOME OF THEM ALMOST GIVE THE
IMPRESSION THAT MAYBE HE WILL
JUST FAIL OR IT WON'T HAPPEN AND
WE WON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH IT.
BUT ENDING LAWLESSNESS AT THE
BORDER IS A BIPARTISAN
OVERWHELMING ISSUE.
STANDING UP TO CHINA AND
DEFENDING AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING.
STANDING UP AGAINST CHEATING AND
FRAUD AND ABUSE IS A BIPARTISAN
POWERFUL ISSUE.
TRUMP IS RIGHT ON BOTH OF THOSE.
AND FIGHTING HER OWN WORDS.
I SAW THAT VETERANS OPPOSED
MILITARY EFFORT IN OUR RACK NOT
JUSTIFIED BY 64%.
AMERICAN PEOPLE THINK THAT WE
ARE TOO COMMITTED INTO MANY
ENDLESS WARS, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
RIGHT ABOUT THAT.
SO I THINK THIS REPRESENTS SOME
CHANGE FOR THE REPUBLICAN
ESTABLISHMENT.
AND MANY OF THE DEMOCRATS,
TOTALLY OPPOSED TO IT.
BUT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO PUT
TOGETHER A MAJORITY, AND WE
SHOULD DRIVE THIS ISSUE.
WE CAN TAKE IT TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND NAME NAMES, AND SHOW WHO IS
FOR WHAT.
AND MAKE THEM VOTE.
THAT'S WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
US DO.
>> Tucker: NAMING NAMES WOULD
BE A GREAT PUBLIC SERVICE.
QUICKLY WE MOVE FROM RUSSIA TO
UKRAINE, THE PRESIDENT IS GOING
TO BE IMPEACHED, WHAT DO YOU
MAKE OF THAT?
>> Tucker: I CANNOT POINT --
>> I CANNOT SEE AN IMPEACHMENT
CASE HERE, A CONTINUOUS ATTACK
FROM DAY ONE, THINGS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE DONE THAT ARE PERFECTLY
INNOCENT, I FELT SOME OF THAT
MYSELF OR CREATED AND TWISTED TO
BE SOMETHING EVIL AND IMPROPER.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS CONDUCTED
HIMSELF IN THIS MATTER WITHIN
THE LAW, AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THERE IS ANYTHING CLOSE TO
AN IMPEACHMENT CASE.
I THINK THE DEMOCRATS WILL
BASICALLY VOTE IT.
IT LOOKS LIKE PRETTY SLINK AWAY,